Normally when you pip install a Python package, it
will download from PyPI, the Python package index.
But did you know that you can actually
pip install directly from GitHub?
Take the git URL to your favorite
project and add "git+" in front.
Then you can just pip install it to try
out the latest commit from that repo.
You can also add an "@" sign with a git reference,
such a branch, tag name, commit hash, or pull
request number to install a specific version.
This can be useful for testing versions of
packages that haven't been officially published
yet, like from a feature branch or a pull request.
It's good practice to also specify the
egg name, which is what pip will treat
this project's name as for the purposes of
dependency checking, so if you later install
another package that depends on the GitHub
one it will know it's already installed.
All this only works if the repo is an
actual Python package with a setup.py file,
not just a lonely script.
Check out my video on automated
testing if you want to see how to set that up.
If the setup.py isn't at the root of the repo,
you can specify it with the
subdirectory query parameter in the URL.